I need other Christopher Nolan shirts I
know you need a Dunkirk shirt I need a
shirt of insomnia yeah or is out of
cheeto Oh watch out Chino lose sleep Oh
guys how you doing I'm Greg I'm John
we're gonna watch the trailer for
Christopher Nolan's Tennant which I hope
has his familiar trailer text on the
screen he must go would it be like this
text is it one we need guys before we
swing on into this reaction I want to
say thank you to all the proper people
who have an Android iOS I for the people
who went to their App Store downloaded
and followed us on the Stardust Africans
we are posting daily over there
constantly for months it's an extension
of the real rejects so you guys should
just go over there down the aisle follow
us add a 30 second reaction reviews for
films TV shows and or trailers and the
whole thing is free so why are you
complaining let's do this
yes No
whoa
[Music]
that's better right Robert Pattinson
okay
Oh
Michel kind maybe
what is happening oh sweet oh sweet whoa
Nolan man he's Josh hasn't happened yet
oh hey so many thoughts oh so many
thoughts so many mysteries
what I love about a Christopher Nolan
film is their movies that he wants you
to experience in the theaters but
they're also you know sometimes he does
like his inceptions or Batman films even
to a certain degree with those but like
things like Dunkirk or even this they're
not the usual blockbuster films they're
different they are driven by story and
mood and tone and I like I was fine ever
like joking about like insomnia and
prestige it kind of seems to have some
of that horror elements that he likes or
like the the tents thriller elements
that he really likes to include in his
films they're somewhat present and some
of other films here you know those shots
are like John David Washington's it felt
like horror movie or something harkening
back to his days of memento yeah oh yeah
that's very before boding and you get a
sense of danger and I love how they ease
in this weird
Time Warp concept you know where you
slowly catch on to the fact that certain
things are moving backwards and other
things are moving forwards around I'm
like it's mind-bending and I have no
idea what exactly the rules are gonna be
or what it's gonna get out but he said
it's like his biggest film in terms of
just like globe-spanning locations and
yeah well it kind of has some of its
inception vibes in terms of like the
sort of sci-fi visual things the stuff
that's unrealistic and seems a bit out
of a dream but he we also know that he
really loves dealing with time I think
Nolan in general even in the Batman
movies he is great at going through like
cutting between many different sequences
and I know and um
riki really deals with different time
moments yeah but even in the Batman
films - it's like cutting around to many
different events happening at one time
and not making it feel like what's going
on or this is confusing but having it be
really intense which is something I
think he mastered watching him really
play with time in a physical way where
it's chained it's altered it's like
changing the reality in before our
characters eyes yeah it's something
that's gonna be very different and
fascinating inception he's dealt with
dreams and here he's dealing with time
and how that manifests in the physical
way I'm excited to see what he's got in
store because it looks like a great sort
of mood piece as well and I thought we
got a little bit more information than
we normally do it and other Nolan films
a little baby you know he said it's
supposed to start out as like an
espionage film and then mix with other
genres and I definitely got that sense
from this I mean obviously there's some
sci-fi there's some horror but curious
to see what else he's gonna throw in
there cuz like Christopher Nolan is one
of the few film makers who can really
make films on a blockbuster scale you
know yeah with all the time and
attention that goes into you know the
story and the writing and all that as
well as the scope and the spectacle and
like that's pretty special that's what I
get excited about what he gets in camera
for these action movies that's what gets
me excited like in terms of watching one
of his films on IMAX and by the way he
is the best at using the IMAX camera
yeah he started it with the Dark Knight
other directors have you know done that
thing where certain scenes are filming
IMAX cameras a lot of times it is just
for the big spectacle moments but when
you watch his movies yeah it's like a
lot of the spectacles the sequences are
an IMAX but he knows how to use it to
make it immersive and to do it based off
the emotion and the mood not so much
like oh this is a cool action scene
let's put in an IMAX cameras yeah like I
there are times where it's just you know
an establishing shot he's got those
great beautiful looking establishing
shots and buildings and stuff but
sometimes it's just a little moment
where you cut to a different scene and
he has it in a big IMAX format because
it helps with the mood and the
transitions as opposed to just that's a
cool moment you know seeing the action
that he has here and then John David
Washington
like I loved him in black Klansmen yeah
and seeing him get to start a Nolan film
is awesome Robert panic what Batman is
now Twilight in here with Nolan who did
a Batman movie connections whoa you see
that cyber multiple universes and
Kenneth Branagh after working with him
in Dunkirk now back here and Elizabeth
debicki is well he he just gets oh he
always has a great cast assemble every
time and it's a great cast yeah and he's
got his regulars but I feel like every
time he also brings in some interesting
new faces speaking of that this is the
first movie in a while without a Hans
Zimmer score that's sure is gonna be
look like the guy who's doing work on
like the Mandalorian right animal a
panther and all that stuff awesome so
many cool things to look forward to
sci-fi spy what does Tennant mean it's a
great question I mean Tennant is I'm
really stupid I thought four months is
called Tennant no oh I'm sure there are
multiple definitions I always thought
tenets were like the pillars of a belief
system but I'm not entirely sure what
contexts are using it here I loved his
yellow look that he always has his DPS
do yellow are you guys excited for the
movie Tennant what are you hoping for
from it what looks different to you do
you think this will be one of nones best
films what gets you most excited in this
trailer watching our video great when
you hear them blowing leaves outside
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
about they get notified whenever we got
a youtube video up download and follow
us on the Stardust app it is a great app
and last but not least I'd like to end
this with a picture of the day shout out
to a man named James no briga so we
message James this you know asking like
hey thanks for joining our page rampage
how are you how'd you find us and he
came back with hey back at you I love
what you guys are doing so I wanted to
support you my wife and I oh man with
the sexy guy in a guitar maybe I had a
chance
our independent artists and understand
how hard it is to support yourself in
the arts well don't ask us to pledge to
your patreon page cheese yeah this is a
one-way street one-way street okay if
you
fifteen for Ash I will pledge $1 it
right will help every chance next year
and considering the patreon approach
maybe we'll see a position of being a
musician I also do video editing and
production awesome awesome
you know everyone who pursues those it's
in success mhm
my love for film and addiction to
watching YouTube reactions and reviews
brought me across you guys what about
like beyond the trailer and Tyrone
Magnus or some I'm sure you got there
first I loved watching your episode
reactions to Cobra Kai that show came
out of nowhere and it was so fun to
rewatch it along with you guys I've been
a huge Star Wars fan the season original
in theaters so seeing you guys doing the
Mandalorian show episodes sold me on
wanting to support you guys thanks mando
thanks for doing what you do and then
you finally answer the question oh yeah
we are originally from the San Jose Bay
Area and just recently moved down to the
Central Valley Fresno area those no wait
nevermind all my sarcastic jokes and
since you live in California we have a
chance of bumping into each other
I just wanna clarify I did not mean it
was just sarcasm no we're pleased xxx
don't please don't spit on me we're
gonna pledge $30 I can't get spit on
again no it was really uncomfortable
yeah I only usually my sarcastic
comments are directed at people who
don't live in California but since you
do I'm sorry we love you I love you
James take all our money
I'll sincere I promise I'll message you
back soups been a little busy lately but
thank you James really appreciate it